[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
excuse me uh i won i won the men's
singles first
first place i was wondering if there's
any prize for me
you're gonna have that
is this the only price yes
okay wait wait wait you still haven't
paid your entry fee
that's 100 euros
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
yo come on
oh sorry man a bit of
underwhelming end but that's good
[Applause]
oh around the net nice
[Music]
okay which one should i use today let's
go go with this
i guess i'll play with this
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
this will be an easy match already yes
very good shot
[Music]
yeah this was a good draw
yeah thanks for the match thank you it
was a good warm-up match
this will be an easy match
who is this guy
thanks that was a good warm-up match for
the next round
[Music]
good spin
it's supposed to be maximum spin
[Music]
[Applause]
snake ah you read the you read the
snake's been pretty well
well there was no spin
[Music]
so
there's still 73 of you guys watching
who haven't subscribed so remember to do
that now
and if you haven't seen our web store
yet go and check out pongfinity door
store we've got some cool
table tennis products until next time